did you see Delia at all there I didn't
I didn't you could use a cross tree at
the Paramount right yeah but a lot of
people were like Chris who you know
there are a lot of people are like yeah
but you're out there chanting down with
Chris yeah they were down with cry ends
Adam with crying's data with we saw
Chris and Brian's better we saw Chris
and Brian's better question should quit
Wow I'm gonna write a song for us I'm
gonna write we both need a life song and
I'm gonna write a theme song for us you
know what I mean like Brendan Schaub
bulls in the UFC tall and strong as you
can see Brian took him made him from
scratch breathe life into his clay no
he's a little gay you know what I
brought a grown man I don't know I don't
like that too much
I don't know I'm spitballing ideas okay
well you know but me oh no no let me see
one sweet you know whatever I will
figure it out oh here we go
I got one that will let me think
no I'm not okay Sean be respectful Brian
it's 7:00 listeners then big round came
along saved his life save your career
now I was doing just fine and in fact
about to give out cuz he does all the
work all day it's not rhyming the songs
not rhyming bro so I don't know if that
I don't know if I like it
do you know what I'm saying ah yeah get
on your knees and thank me every single
day this little birds trying to fly you
will never you just yeah that's right
well I made you from scratch you're like
a chicken that's about to hatch you
don't have wings until I say you are you
know now I'm soon and I'm dropping sort
of so you know that I can shoot you out
of the sky when a time I won't any time
I won't
I don't like don't you forget that guy I
don't like this song okay but I'm just
saying I don't like your belt health
legit are those those are pretty bad hey
Silvana come pick up you just the Year
bail Michael rap boards not gonna be
happy dude this is all I've ever wanted
to first load logos from the day one
logo to the find the kid looks is
amazing on this please which company
made these Jenny's buted belts 83 and 67
hey I need
can we please can we
a couple sweatshirts and t-shirts will
run the weekend each I'd like to do a
run of the a bikini that was original
and this one I love this one you know
what I mean I'd love to do that the one
the one love shirt sold out I love those
one love shirts
there's everybody's been hitting me up
with one love like when I take pictures
they're all like one there on the right
hey let me take a picture with the gay
owl or one love but that's a special one
love but whatever oh I know that right
there is great in that belt sweet yeah
once Theo von I if I had four hundred
million dollars I swear to God do that I
would too I really would I want to be
that rich and I would just be like James
now I'm off to you guys now listen James
up when I'm informally uses a [ __ ] pad
so you have to get rid of your kid
that's quick yeah okay now this is gonna
sting a little bit I know now listen now
listen I know it's Christmas but man go
through a you know the rules bro I'm
Horning know you have your family out
except a couple whole you gotta get your
family out cuz I gotta get this dick out
yeah he's been out cuz I'm dropping some
good yeah you can get this deck
Christmas Day
just some Miami Brazilian I need you to
get to all that closed-circuit TV
boarded up as well can't have any no you
can stay but you have to get the wife
and kids out
I got a hazmat team and also I need to
get down all the family pigs is that
that's a bump the family kids the family
pigs
that's a boner kill so go ahead and take
those down some out though me I've been
I've been I've been you know gifting
gifting my wife with my essence and I'll
hear instance upstairs and I'm like
that's my daughter and I don't have a
lock on my office and I'm like well I
just lost my the middle of the day know
at night kid get scared of some I'm
married there's no such thing as that um
yeah no it's and I'm like I'm like oh
and then I just I can't like no game
over kids involved can't do it it's a
lot of information and I'm alright keep
it I don't know if there's no cameras
right now Jesus dude all right
um the by well see what how about our
testosterone spiked because because
Simon watch me manipulate manipulate
Brendan in the hallway
downunder hooks I went hips I went head
how dare you embarrass me in front of
feel my yeah it was right in the hallway
in front of let me yeah I just saw Theo
down the hall grew who will agrees the
greatest human being on the planet Earth
see right
antic very tight if he was a stock I'd
invest in the bank but I don't know if
that's an option it's a very good way to
put it you know they used to actually
have it's a great compliment to a
comedian no I tell him that all the time
he's he makes me feel some love in my
heart that not too many comedians no
offense yeah I'd love a like a Care Bear
remember the Care Bear yes the flowers
your heart right while you guys are like
getting low and fighting he's loving and
hugging you already never see anyone
like you
oh he's like that guy well he'll also
the way he was raised and ran is also
unique because what if you notice when I
was attacking him what did he do he play
I'm done he clammed I do nothing but I
thought that was his defense because he
doesn't like law policy doesn't like his
conserving his energy for no he doesn't
like anybody who is like a talented guy
like yourself an artist he doesn't want
anybody to know what a brute he actually
said three dudes talk you feel like you
probably conversation I feel like I knew
you guys already because I listened to
the podcast I'm familiar with you guys
so coming and I have an idea of I'm like
okay you were comfortable right away you
know to me because I I somewhat had a
pulse on your guy's vibe us that listens
it's off your vibe you speak the
language right right like one of us any
lives in Venice how do I get in the gang
what do I got an issue I initiate you I
mean if this suck is dick well well well
we get our hands on you and we see when
guffy up a little boring I gotta take
your piece in we got to see what goes on
you lot bum me out is I love Howard
Stern right he's the Godfather is the
best right he's hating on podcasting the
other day and it broke my heart was like
oh really because and I do this thing
you might not sure knowledge well the
situation I'll see podcasting was bit of
a threat to that's what I was meant to
say it's 10 he goes does anyone even
make money doing pot like how the [ __ ]
would you ain't money because why would
you listen to that and all the stuff and
then the guy goes yeah you know it's
broken
he brings up Joey goes you know Rogan
like man those guys have big podcast man
and
but how juniors how do they do I know
yours Rona made money off that pot
comedy and TV he has no I was like
erious but you'd be one of us my man if
you didn't sell out hasn't made that
trend like it is basically a pod makes
500 million years he's doing just so
he's like I don't what he's doing just
what yeah yeah and off see podcast is a
threat to what he does because you have
to pay to listen to him right right
right right
tell me who we're the followers gonna go
right